as a birthday gift zoe gave her niece an
electronic piggy bank that displays the
total amount of money in the bank as
well as the total number of coins after
depositing some number of nickels and
quarters only so we only have nickels
and quarters the display read money two
dollars number of coins 16. how many
nickels and quarters did zoe put in the
banks let's define some variables here
let's let let's let n equal
the number
of nickels
and let's let me write let here
let's let
q be equal to
the number
of quarters
the number of quarters so how many total
coins do we have what's going to be the
number of nickels plus the number of
quarters so we have the nickels plus the
quarters
need to be equal to well it tells us we
have 16 total coins so if we add up the
total number of nickels plus the number
of quarters we have 16 coins so that's
one equation right there
and then how much total money do we have
well
however many nickels we have we can
multiply that times
0.05 and that'll tell us how much money
we have in nickels so
0.05 times the nickels
plus the amount of money we have in
quarters well that'll just be 25 cents
per quarter or
0.25 of a dollar
so let me write
0.25 times the number of quarters for
example if i had four quarters and no
nickels i'd have four times 25 cents
which is one dollar and no money due to
nickels so however many nickels times
five cents plus however many quarters
times 25 cents that's the total amount
of money i have and her piggy bank tells
me that that is two dollars
that is equal to two dollars so we have
two equations with two unknowns we can
solve for n and q
and let's do it by substitution so let's
see the easiest thing that we could do
here
let's solve
let's solve for q over here so if n plus
q is equal to 16 we can subtract n from
both sides of this equation so if n plus
q
is equal to 16 if we subtract n from
both sides we get q is equal to 16
minus n so all i did is i rewrote this
first constraint right over there
so since this first constraint is
telling us that q the number of quarters
must be 16 minus the number of nickels
in the second constraint every place
that we see a q every place we see a
quarters we can replace it with 16 minus
n so let's do that so the second
constraint when we make the substitution
becomes
0.05
n
plus
0.25 instead of q i'm going to write 16
minus n
minus n that's what the first constraint
tells us q must be 16 minus n
that is going to be equal to two dollars
we're solving the system by substitution
now let's see if i can simplify this so
0.05 n
plus let's distribute the 0.25 times the
16 and the 0.25 times the negative n
0.25 times 16 that's the same thing as 1
4 times 16 that's just going to be 4
and then 0.25 times negative n is
minus
0.25
n and that is going to be equal to two
dollars let me scroll down a little bit
actually i could continue i'll scroll
down a little bit see we have
0.05 n
minus
0.25 n so if i have 0.05 minus 0.25 so
let me combine these terms
so if i have 0.05 of something and i'm
going to subtract from that .25 of that
something that'll give me negative 0.20
of that something if i combine these two
terms i get negative .20 or negative 0.2
n and then of course i have the plus
four
plus four
is equal to two dollars or we could even
just write two there
now we can isolate the n the left hand
side by subtracting four from both sides
so let's subtract 4 from both sides and
we are left with on the left hand side
negative i can just write that as
negative
0.20 n is equal to 2 minus 4 is negative
is equal to negative 2 and then we can
divide both sides by negative point two
divide both sides by negative zero point
two or i could write negative point zero
negative zero point two zero the same
thing
we're not going to
go too deep into the significant digits
and all of that we're assuming that we
have infinite precision on everything so
negative 2 divided by negative 0.2
these guys cancel out and we are left
with n
is equal to
the negatives cancel out 2 divided by
0.2 is just going to be 10.
n is equal to 10. and then we know that
q is equal to 16 minus n from the first
constraint q
is equal to 16 minus n which is 10 which
is going to be 6. so zoe put in 10
nickels
she put in 10 nickels i want to do that
in a different color she put in 10
nickels and 6 quarters
and six quarters in the bank and we can
verify it so clearly she has 16 coins so
that part makes sense 10 nickels 6
quarters that's 16 coins that makes
sense and we can also verify this the
right amount of money
10 nickels 10 nickels are going to be 50
cents 10 times
10 times 5 cents each so it's going to
be 50 cents
and then six quarters
six quarters is going to be a dollar
fifty
so it's going to be a dollar fifty so
the total amount of money she has is 50
cents plus a dollar fifty which is two
dollars so it all works out